washington kündigt die aufstellung einer
space for sein während moskau neue
waffen vorstellt die auch im weltraum
eingesetzt werden können
china und indien positionieren sich im
globalen wettlauf und sogar frankreich
möchte eine eigene weltraum truppe das
rennen um die dominanz im all ist voll
im gange heute in vechta kompakt
wettrüsten im alter die nutzung des alls
diente lange fast ausschließlich zivilen
zwecken
die alltägliche abhängigkeit ist enorm
gestiegen große handelsströme werden
über satelliten gesteuert kein tv-sender
oder internet und kommunikationsanbieter
kann ohne sie auskommen
die großmächte usa russland china sowie
indien haben eigene
navigationssatelliten für zivile und
militärische zwecke positioniert das eu
system galileo gilt als modernstes und
präzises das system steht unter ziviler
kontrolle und soll 2020 in vollbetrieb
gehen
allein die usa betreiben 849 der
insgesamt etwa 2000 satelliten und 67
davon für militärische zwecke präsident
raum stellte dazu fest dass eine präsenz
im alt nicht ausreiche
man müsse die dominanz haben schon in
den 1980 er jahren verfolgten die usa
die strategic defense initiative auch
star wars genannt heute posieren sie ein
weltraum gestütztes sensoren netzwerk
gegen anfliegende raketen inklusive der
modernsten hyperschall flugkörper
geplant ist auch die stationierung von
abfangraketen zur raketenabwehr im
bildraum häufig werden boden luft oder
all gestützte leser waffen erwähnt die
allerdings aufgrund ihres enormen
energiebedarf nur schwer zu realisieren
sind
frankreich möchte anti satelliten leser
waffen im weltraum für rein defensive
zwecke entwickeln
paris vorstellen länger mit deutschland
an laserwaffen gemeinsam betreiben sie
aufklärungssatelliten china russland
indien und die usa haben bereits
demonstriert dass sie satelliten
abschießen können moderne kriegsführung
ist ohne satelliten
nicht mehr vorstellbar über sie werden
angriff und abwehr akten gesteuert
militärische einrichtungen überwacht
truppenbewegungen verfolgt oder
bestimmte gebiete beobachtet infrarot
kameras können zum beispiel feststellen
ob kampfjets oder drohnen im einsatz
waren oder nur abgestellt sind
es hat eliten werden dabei zwangsläufig
zu angriffszielen übliche methoden sind
ihre kommunikation zu stören
chieming sie zu manipulieren oder zu
täuschen spoofing sie zu blenden oder zu
zerstören
sie könnten auch gehackt werden ohne
dass es der gegner märkte international
besonders kritisiert wird eine
stationierung von waffen im an etwa von
sogenannten kilo satelliten die sich
andere nähern und durch explosionen
zerstören können satelliten können auch
durch raketen von der erde oder von
flugzeugen aus abgeschossen werden aber
durch jede zerstörung entstehen tausende
teilchen die als weltraumschrott andere
satelliten gefährden
die vermehrte abstützung auf satelliten
durch streitkräfte hat zu einer
zunehmenden militarisierung des weltalls
geführt man spricht bereits vom fünften
operationsraum zusätzlich zu land wasser
luft und dem cyber raum
damit wird auch die aufstellungen
eigenen teilzeitkraft der space fonds
begründet die meist aus bisherigen
einheiten der luftwaffe formiert wird
sie hat folgende einsatzbereiche er
stehe in der weltraum lage aufklärung
spionage und frühwarnung vor raketen
kommunikation und navigation steuerung
von waffensystemen wie zum beispiel
drohnen oder marschflugkörper sowie die
stationierung von waffen im all die
militärische nutzung des weltalls kann
offensiv oder defensiv erfolgen was aber
nur schwer zu trennen ist defensive
maßnahmen dienen dem schutz des eigenen
landes eigener systeme und deren
einsatzfähigkeit der offensive bereich
verfolgt hingegen den einsatz eigener
waffensysteme für angriffs weg
dazu gehört vor allem der geplante
einsatz von ihm als stationierten waffen
oder die steuerung eigen
raketen zur rechtlichen situation ist
besteht zwar ein vertrag über die
friedliche nutzung des weltraums aus 19
67 der die stationierung von
massenvernichtungswaffen militärische
test sowie jegliche militärische
installationen auf einen himmelskörpern
verbietet er verbietet aber zum beispiel
nicht die detonation von atomwaffen im
weltraum wodurch raketen abgefangen oder
satelliten zerstört werden können
auch die durchquerung des alls mit
konventionell bestückten raketen ist
nicht erfasst
seit 1982 versucht daher die
abrüstungskonferenz der uno in genf ein
abkommen zur verhinderung eines
wettrüstens im all zu erzielen bisher
vergeblich china und russland
präsentierten 2014 einen entwurf die usa
lehnen aber umfassende und verbindliche
regelungen ab zahlreiche un resolutionen
blieben ohne konkrete ergebnisse ein
ausblick das weltall ist zur
unverzichtbaren domäne geworden für
zivile und militärische zwecke die
vormachtstellung der usa ist zwar noch
gegeben durch die anderen großmächte
unternehmen erhebliche anstrengungen
diese dominanz zu überwinden
daher wird es in absehbarer zeit auch
keine wirksamen rüstungskontrolle
abkommen geben
vom krieg der sterne sind wir zwar noch
weit entfernt
das wettrüsten und die militarisierung
des weltraums sind aber bereits ein
faktum